[MUSIC]
If you grew up in Mexico you grew up going
to bakeries every day, the smells and
the flavors, just the experience to
pick the bundles and to pick the bread.
My mom didn't like that I
grabbed the tray and the tongs,
because I used to pile the tray up high.
That's something that we wanted
to replicate here in the US.
Ricardo and I met in business school.
We actually were from
the same city in Mexico.
We hadn't met until we
both were at Stanford.
When we moved to LA,
we saw that that tradition was there
amongst the Latino communities.
But there wasn't necessarily a place that
reflected exactly what it was like to
be home.
That's the beginning of this idea.
>> We are in our store in Highland Park
northeast of downtown Los Angeles,
very dense Hispanic community,
working class neighborhood.
There is a lot of activity from
very early on in the morning,
you see people coming and going.
>> We've always tried to hire locally and
we make sure our products
are made from scratch.
>> My favorite items on the menu, the
concha which is a traditional sweet bread.
We have breakfast tacos in the morning.
>> We make an ocha latte which,
that's pretty good over ice.
>> When we first opened, we learned a lot
by just being at the first location.
Pretty much all the time,
we actually, we would sleep there.
If you're thinking of
doing your own business,
there's never going to be a better time
to do it than right after you graduate.
The opportunity cost of
just deciding to go for
it is the lowest it's ever going to be.
>> Some of the classes that I remember
from the GSB, performance leadership,
the entrepreneurship
classes were terrific.
>> They have a lot of lessons and
teachings about how to
run an organization and how really it
comes down to building effective teams.
One of the gifts of going to
the GSB is the alumni community.
>> Some of the advisers of
our company are GSB alumni.
So most,
if not all of our success is due to them.
To create company culture
is a daily things.
It's with the way we act, not only with
our employees, but with our customers,
with our suppliers.
I derive the most pleasure from people.
You really have to enjoy people
to be in the restaurant business.
That gives me great joy.
>> I really like going our stores and
just talking to our staff.
It's actually a little dangerous,
because you can spend a whole
day just talking to our team.
>> Nobody goes angry into a bakery, which
is another plus of being in this business.
[MUSIC]